uh let's go next to our caller from the
978
area code who's calling today from nine
seven eight
hi i'm brett fitzgibbons i'm sorry did
you say your name's brett
brett yes what's going on brett
well let me tell you something i've
i put in my application to city hall for
a mail on ballot
yeah and it was it was never delivered
by the
by the post office okay let's back up
brett where
so where what part of the country are
you talking about you're here in boston
um on the north north shore north shore
okay
and did you call and ask what's going on
with your ballot
yeah i did and that's they told me they
mailed them out a week ago
and it was never delivered yeah you so i
actually
it took me three weeks to get mine
and um i when i called they said and
this is a
quote it's because of what's going on
with the post office which struck me as
very ominous so i mean i do think you're
now you're talking about for the
september first primary right
yeah yeah which is just a few guys
i was asking for the mail on ballot for
the presidential
but they don't go over it wait wait a
second hold on let me back up brett are
you
are you saying you you're waiting on the
ballot for november
yeah oh no they haven't sent those out
yet there hasn't there's still a primary
on september 1st it's fine
you shouldn't have gotten the november
ballot yet that's normal nobody's gotten
it yet in massachusetts
i've got no ballot smell to me did you
request
the democratic primary ballot because
you do have to request that you should
i did yeah you did okay so that's the
one i'd be concerned about the november
one not so much
uh it's yeah it's a problem now if you
don't get it by september 1st will you
go in and vote in person
we've got well we got early voting right
now oh okay
i have to go down and vote this week
you're going to do it okay very good
well yeah i mean listen it's a mess i'm
hearing these stories from all over the
country
yes it's a crime yeah
all right my friend brett thank you for
the call uh great to hear from you and
uh yet another
data point um about how bad it is
uh with a lot of this um uh post office
shenanigans
that are going on let's take a quick
break if you're holding
don't hang up because i'm going right
back to the phones momentarily